hey guys Ryan right here hey guys
salamander and I are gonna check out
this video
reactors age of troll Tron there was a
reactors assemble video I saw which was
[ __ ] awesome by edik the one except
Sally wasn't in it which really pissed
off a lot of people specifically her and
her family haha
man that [ __ ] kid outside every every
weekend when I film there's always a
[ __ ] kid oh yeah sure okay this was
apparently the first one by JC Georgy or
JG Georgi I forgot dude I'm sorry I
don't have your YouTube channel up right
now but this is reactors age of Charl
Tron I'm assuming I'm also in this one
which is gonna make my life worth it and
I'm assuming Sally's not in it which is
gonna be punishing for her when I box
playing right yeah
the happiest home
Daniel
well the means Oh totally met this guy
when I did the first livestream event
really yeah impressive well thank you
dude I'm glad to be featured in that you
should do one where it's all the female
rejects yeah that would be cool I'm
assuming you want to be black with it
yeah I actually auditioned for a
commercial as Black Widow for a Marvel
thing how'd it go I got a callback which
is awesome did you book it
yeah how unfortunate you booked the
audition how sad for everyone anyway you
cry
are you crying you [ __ ] cry ha ha
[ __ ] crier this is what happens when
you get featured in videos as you you
realize how how drunk with power you
become Sally knows I don't really mean
that even when my jokes are extreme I
still hope she's like he's just joking
yeah rhyme right yeah dude that was
great
you know I I didn't talk enough in it so
I'm kind of upset about that but your
facial expressions
he always had me smiling I was the
happiest hope you could ever see well I
just think I just think okay look I'm
grateful I'm totally grateful absolutely
but I just think it could use a little
bit more you know screen time and a
little bit more dialog it's all good
even stealing some noises stolen some
it's a li this is my time to talk real
fast I think you should redo it and
feature me more no no come on do it I'm
totally grateful totally grateful just
redo it and now that's great yeah
something like that
anyway as I love shout outs if you guys
are new to the channel you can subscribe
to the real rejects where we're so real
with everything we talk about oh my god
it's just like this is the most sincere
channel you'll ever come across
Sally has a channel it's so much fun you
will go there and I swear you'll be like
wow my day is so much better now that I
have seen Sally's channel
yeah okay and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter or we
need more followers because we're trying
to beat some people to the finish line
right now there's a certain number we're
trying to get to and we're in a
competition that's funny because I feel
like I'm above Taylor Lautner the
greatest action alex gomez okay can I
please get a shout-out and remember kids
don't listen to Ryan that must mean
you're a kid look at this guy he's a
Hispanic dude he looks so Asian or he
might be Asian she does have a Filipino
nose yeah yeah yeah man
okay cool you're young so like I say I
got to keep it appropriate because
they're young but here's what I'll tell
you now as a piece of advice don't look
at a woman like they're objects look at
them like they're goals like okay as a
young person now I should study woman
I'm assuming you're still not a teenager
yet so I'm assuming having gone through
puberty yet but once you go through
puberty you're gonna want to do stuff
with other girls
every parents talk to you about sexual
intercourse cuz you're probably gonna
want to do that and so I'm saying study
now you clearly get online access buddy
some sex vidiots you I'm just hey you
said kids don't listen to me so he's
fine